hey how's it going bros - better pack
welcome chi-chi-chi shakin this is the
game where you build just chickens I
think I'm just gonna do the quick
tutorial what the actual [ __ ]
okay so in this game you can pretty much
build whatever you want and it will
become a living thing so let's try and
build up something and see what happens
or something that's okay let's try and
build a dog wow what a hot dog this is
Emma right ladies
oh my god no let's give it him out it's
a dog right so we better give it a dog
mouth whatever whatever whatever that is
there there it is that's that's the dog
that's that's a dog that's that's a dog
mouth right there okay oh God how are
you doing there buddy is he moving at
all
it's moving
science probably has gone too far yes
you are right what's better than a dog
penis a dog penis that can fly go ahead
go ahead you're welcome go which will
take over these lands we were all meant
to fly
you're not flying you're a piece of [ __ ]
dog penis what are you doing
god damn it dog penis so annoying I just
want to build like the saddest thing
alive
okay whatever this is supposed to be the
living pizza slice let's see how it
looks like
soon a good job I'm proud of my little
pizza hey follow me Pisa let's go on
adventure The Adventures of Pewter pizza
I just got an amazing idea what the [ __ ]
is that I'm actually trying here guys
this game is [ __ ] hilarious
and insane I feel like I'm going insane
while playing this alright let's give
this baby the fur it deserves get it
yep that that looks that looks so good
that looks amazing
oh my god it looks so good let's put the
ice this is way better than I could have
possibly ever dreamed dreamt about yeah
that's that's how I look like duh [ __ ]
hahahaha ok go far Donald Trump my sweet
child
how are ya been a great building is for
the lucky building for me so let's see
what happens you look fantastic today
Donald so the other day we lost two
kisses should we we should really one
humming that's impossible that son
you're right
there's immigrants over here Donald yeah
there's immigrants for you to feast upon
it's sad how hard I'm trying and how
[ __ ] it becomes they said there can only
be one Trump but who can trump the Trump
if not another Trump what did my other
Trump go the [ __ ] is he doing over there
hey I got you your girlfriend well
follow me Jesus Christ Jesus Christ this
is out of control
Trump won calling Trump won what are you
doing over here
oh my god that is some kinky [ __ ]
shame grumpy you have nipples seconds
pierce oh god oh god he does not want to
communicate does it move is it alive I
don't think anything is this disgust oh
god oh god why oh holy [ __ ] that looks
awesome
good hey you're just gonna hate hate
it's gonna
Oh God is trying to escape Kelly we
can't let it out in the wild who knows
what he will do with our ecosystem it's
really trying to escape I feel bad there
you go
you're coming with me [ __ ]
that's right back to present [ __ ]
nothing this ugly deserves to live this
is so fun it's so dumb but it's so fun
alright go far ha ha ha
um 12 yep oh god what is he asleep like
what does he do is looking at me this is
all right this game is pure art I love
it ok so this game is still in early
development I having so much fun
checking it out I hope you bros enjoyed
as well if you did why don't they were
like it really helps out a lot let me
know if you want to play more of this
and that's all I'll do for now as always
stay awesome
we got a level pack - Oh a stamp well I
guess I'll just put just kidding